الصين تاخرت وتحاول اللحاق بالركب فصولات
وحليفها روسي وجولات الامريكيين في عالم
الفضاء تكبرها بكثير بكين ارسلت ثلاثه
روات فضاء من بينهم مدني للمره الاولى في
تاريخها باتجاه محطه يانجونغ الصينيه
الفضائيه الخاصه بها وبمهمه وصفت بالتجربه
الثمينه لهذا العملاق الاسيوي
هي محطه الفضاء المعياريه الكبيره الصينيه
هي محطه فضاء تدور في مدار ارضي منخفض بين
كيلومترا
و540 كيلومترا فوق السطح تعد جزءا من
الخطوه الثالثه لبرنامج الفضاء الصيني
الماهول وستكون محطه بعد اكتمالها في خمس
حجم محطه الفضاء الدوليه وبنفس حجمها
تطمير الروسيه المحطه الصينيه معياريه من
الجيل الثالث كالمحطتين اللتين سبق ذكرهما
اي انه جرى تجميعها في المدار من اجزاء
اطلقت بشكل منفصل تساهم اساليب التصميم
المعياريه بتحسين الموثوقيه بشكل كبير
وايضا خفض التكاليف وتقصير دوره التطوير
وتلبيه متطلبات مهام متنوعه يجب التحكم
بالمحطه من مركز بكين الجو فضائي للتحكم
والسيطره وتهدف الى توفير فرص لتجارب
الفضائيه وحتى بناء القدره على الابتكار
العلمي والتكنولوجي شمل التصميم الاولي
للمحطه لثلاث وحدات حتى نهايه العام
الماضي مع امكانيه اضافه ست وحدات مستقبلا
ويفترضوا ان تبقى في المدار لعشر سنوات
على الاقل كانت انطلقت الوحده الرئيسيه في
محطه يانجونغو والمسماه او تناغم السماوات
كانت انطلقت في التاسع والعشرين من ابريل
2021 توفر هذه الوحده اي مقصوره دعما
واماكن معيشيه لثلاثه روات فضاء تشمل
ادوات التوجيه الملاحه تحكم بالمحطه وتوفر
ايضا انظمه الطاقه تتكون الوحده من ثلاثه
اقسام اماكن المعيشه قسم الخدمه وايضا
نقطه الالتحام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات